sa patine encore ce mercredi sur la
route presque habitué les automobilistes
vigilants adoptent une conduite prudente
mais ce matin ça va ça va très bien
à 7h30 c'était un peu dur mais bon vu
que à Montigny ça a pas été déneigé
depuis hier 19h et jusqu'à ce mardi 4h30
la casse qui a assuré trois épandages de
bouillie de sel et trois sorties de
lames pour déneigées les patrouilles
n'ont depuis signalé aucun problème de
voirie elles sont d'astreinte depuis le
début de l'hiver au départ on avait donc
1200 tonnes de sel de départ voilà là
aujourd'hui il doit me rester un peu
près 180 tonnes
je pense une 35 35 fois au moins elle
sera un réseau de 200 km à chaque fois
dans chaque sortie du côté de la SNCF
les prévisions annoncées ont été tenues
avec des difficultés ponctuelles sur
notre secteur notamment des
dysfonctionnements de mécanismes de
porte et du givre formé sur les
caténaires des rames stationnés cette
nuit à Trappes qui ont entraîné des
retards et suppression
ça se passe pas tout simplement
normalement je travaille à la défense
mais de toute façon ça fait il y a plus
de train donc peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
on a je vais essayer de voir sinon j'ai
la chance d'avoir des bureaux aussi sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc voilà je
me repis ici quand je peux pas y aller
la société skibus a suspendu son trafic
toute la matinée certains usagers ont
été prévenus par SMS d'autres ont
attendu en 20 leur bus la solution de
repli le taxi on a beaucoup de monde on
n'arrive pas à fournir des gens arrêtent
pas d'appeler on est peu nombreux à
travailler évidemment avec les
conditions donc ouais il y a beaucoup de
monde là ça s'est calmé mais depuis ce
matin ça n'arrêtait pas
si la neige perturbe les transports elle
facilite les descente en luge et fait le
bonheur des enfants reste à remonter la
pente